yo bullet head podcast man
uh this guy right here his new project
is out he's fresh out well
i mean it's been a few weeks since
you've been out like three now like
fresh out from like after the election
right yeah
yo the homie draco the ruler is is here
welcome sir welcome home too man
exactly i've seen you everywhere making
all the stops
yeah i was just telling tk how impressed
i was we were just talking about
just the work ethic how fast you cranked
out a whole project and it wasn't like
it was an ep
yeah like like like how like
first of all what about two and a half
weeks you recorded this thing
i really recorded it in like
like five days but it took a little
minute to
for my engineer to mix everything were
you
like when you're locked up i know you
got to be writing right yeah of course
every day were you getting like you
weren't getting beats though
nah sometimes i was listening i was
listening to a lot of beats but
most of this [ __ ] i was just writing
like just trying to keep a melody in my
head and just writing it
i didn't know that it was just going to
go to most of the beats that i was doing
but yeah that [ __ ] is crazy so a lot of
the records that you wrote you came out
and just applied those to beats that you
found yeah basically
i started most of the [ __ ] was jig bees
but that's when i did the tape in jail
and then
other [ __ ] i was like i wrote it like
two weeks before i got out
help me understand we know the truth
what are you referring to what's the
truth i'm the truth that's
just we know the truth like didn't go
down
and you know everything like me being in
jail everything i went through
all the people that got on when i was in
jail just everybody know the truth
it's like when i got out everybody like
oh yeah like it's over for a lot of
people
you know the real is here i just like we
know the truth that's why i wanted to
it's interesting because
you know yourself and greedo i feel like
kind of really helped kick off a wave in
l.a
yeah um and i don't think a lot of
people
well like you said we know the truth i
understand what you're alluding to
but i don't think a lot of people um
understand that
fully yeah um and it's it's it was
it was bad that you know both of y'all
ended up going away
yeah you know what i'm saying i'm free
greedo but
uh now that you're out
you've seen a lot of people pop right
a lot of people who maybe borrow from
what you do sonically a lot of people
right um what is what is the like like
like you didn't expect to get out of
jail no
not like that right so now that you're
home like like how do you feel about
just the
the landscape of la hip-hop from when
you went into where it is now
i mean it's cool because it's a lot more
like
young people that's on now there's not
as many like older people that's like
trying to like
hog it and [ __ ] like and trying to not
like put people on as more young people
now
so i kind of like that because when i
was first rapping like i was getting
into it with all the older dudes because
they want to help us out
so when i came to jail it's like all the
people that was like under me are like
you know like looked up to me they all
started getting on so i kind of like it
it's kind of cool
you know yeah there's like a whole like
wave of guys like ruchi like what
jay chike like there's like and also i
feel like two was dope about the lac and
it's for the most part
for the most part it seems like a lot of
camaraderie yeah yeah
i don't run the muzzle for the most part
i mean it's la you
they ain't gonna be a lot like you can't
ever say it's a you know everyone's cool
because it's la this is politics
but but it feels like you know you'll
see ruchi jumping on records with
legit like you see everyone working
together for the most part
um that's got to feel dope and then
obviously you're you come home you're
like
you're like a lot of these kids og which
is kind of crazy to say yeah
yeah cause i'm not even that old but i'm
an old [ __ ] now like
am i like my generation i'm old now
though
i guess uh were you um like i don't know
what
were you able to get access to to music
and [ __ ] while you were locked up
yeah i heard a lot of a lot of stuff
when i was a lot tell you
who that that's popped off since you
were in jail
like do you appreciate their music from
from the city like you know because
there's been a lot
uh it's been a short time it's been
three years right three years
three years a lot happened yeah a lot of
man i guess uh
one take jay uh
like bino uh i like blast
i like it's a lot of people though like
there's
so many people like man lie
i ain't really like i don't know so many
people and so many people like
i don't know but that was like the main
ones that i like uh let me ask you this
because
when nipsey died it hit the city like a
tidal wave i had never seen bro
bigger than even when kobe died rest in
peace to kobe yeah but you being in jail
and experiencing that
you know whether or not you had a
relationship with him just being from la
what was that like ex
like like going through a loss like that
for la like while you're locked up like
what was the temperament inside
i mean it was crazy because i ain't that
was the only person that i could just
like
be like all right that's cool we still
come to the hood and stuff like that
so after that i was like yeah i ain't
coming back like
i'm not gonna be driving the hood doing
the same stuff like
i'm like yeah that could happen to
anybody that was the only person i could
say that was doing that so i'm like nah
oh no she kind of had me like nah i
gotta stay away when i get out
yeah it's almost like it it shows you
like even like
you know with all the positivity he was
bringing to his neighborhood it didn't
matter
yeah basically like people don't care
they just hate us like
is that something because you know i
think that a lot of people they
they they'll go to jail to come out and
you know they don't necessarily change
their
um their habits yeah their circle
yeah is that something like when you're
when you're in there thinking about like
[ __ ]
when i get out i got to reevaluate this
this this
oh yeah for sure for sure it's a lot of
people i'm dealing with that right now
yeah i got it yeah that's all i was
thinking about
who to keep around who not to keep
around how was it gonna be
i just didn't know it was gonna be like
this when i got out like people was
telling me in jail like you don't know
like it'll be people that just came to
jail like you don't know bro like
you know you think you know like but you
don't know how it's gonna be when you
get all like
you like it's a whole different like you
way bigger than what you think bro you
just been in jail for a long time so you
don't know
then when i got i was like wow it is
different like it's crazy now
yeah i mean i mean gifted a curse right
you're going to jail almost added to
like the allure of
of your of you as an artist yeah pretty
much kind of like when boozy got out he
was
you know what i'm saying like it just
added to yeah
like you know what i'm saying like and i
think also your the circumstances of
your case
yeah that too were very it felt like
some [ __ ]
yeah so even people who necessarily
weren't tapped in with your music when
they found out about what was going on
they were like yo this is crazy like
people are just rooting for you you know
what i'm saying yeah
there's a lot of people who wasn't a lot
of people who wasn't rooting for me
me who who wasn't rooting for you i'm
not saying to say names but like who
like the older
the people that have been in the game
for a minute um la rappers
yep that's fair i could see that
yeah yo um did
what what do you think because it was
this judge that was really she had like
a vendetta for you right
she was because she did not like me at
all i don't know what it was like
maybe because i was a rapper because she
told me that incorrectly i don't know if
you think because you're a rapper like
you don't got to listen to the rules i'm
like
you could have just said this for the
gym don't make it seem like you don't
like me bro like
it's almost like they're setting an
example or some [ __ ] pretty much that's
exactly what it was i mean i was
yeah i still was trying it didn't work
though so then she got bounced
right in the election is that what
happened that's the d.a yeah
she got or the the it was the dna was
indiana judge
the d.a and the judge but once the
election happened yeah she got kicked
the book
it almost happened like simultaneously
it was like the election happened and it
was like oh he's coming home yeah
pretty much yeah all of a sudden that's
they had a deal all of a sudden
you can go home right now i'm like after
all this like
y'all could have been letting me go
right right right right how many um
you know it's crazy because in in the
music industry we have
a lot of people who are acquaintances
yeah very few people who are real
friends
yeah right yeah you make music with a
lot of people
yeah um who was checking in on you the
most while you were locked up
in the hip-hop community outside i mean
i'm you know artist wise
shy glizzy all black
oh geezy uh
[Music]
yeah nobody else besides like nah just
them
a little yachty hey lil yachty not
nobody else
yo yachty is always tapped in bro yeah
and he's on the album
yeah he on there were you you guys you
guys had a relationship prior to
yeah i was yeah i was [ __ ] him that's
my boy
yo um what what what date did you get
locked up
january 6 2018.
it's crazy how many people's careers are
over since then yeah
yeah crazy a lot of people came and went
came and went in two years yeah
i mean you know you can only be you can
only make so many memes out of you
before you get tired of that like before
the music has to catch up yeah i mean
like the music got to be good eventually
yeah at some point it's like all right
it was funny now
it jokes up right is that something for
you like getting out and and this there
now there's tick tock
yeah like now there's trailers like this
[ __ ] that wasn't going on when you
went in that's what make me like yeah i
got to be like a dancer [ __ ] to get
home
because every person that i didn't heard
of like i didn't hurt that song like
it'd be hard
and then i thought that he got a dance
dude and that's what blew it up like man
i'm not a dancer bro
like um like and like tick-tock is like
the one
app that like if you're like a real one
you like you're like dog that's goofy
yeah like i mean i made one just because
they made it you got to make one but i
was just right
right right right right all right bro
like uh tick tock
yes what is the one thing that changed
since you went in like since you got out
whether it's tick tock or the industry
or whatever that like
surprised you the most when you got out
man this covet 19
[ __ ] man i didn't know it was this
serious with the mask and all that like
they really like
i was in the beverly center like you had
to put your mask on i'm like it is on i
just pulled it down to drink something
bro like
hey it was tripping on me everybody
kicked me out the wall i was like bro
this is not that serious bro so in jail
they weren't like
no all they would do is like quarantine
like the whole row and then
and two weeks later it's like okay you
guys are all cool now
i'm like damn it like they didn't test
you yeah they tested everybody
yeah that [ __ ] hurt oh that [ __ ] it's
like a brain tumor yeah
i was like when i seen it on the
commercial i didn't think it was like
that but they stuck it all the way up
there like oh no
i started pulling back it was stuck in
there i've never done cocaine but i just
assumed that that might be what it feels
like
and uh yeah i've never i've never put
nothing in my nose yeah
i'm scared but i wanted to when i did i
was like this would be like the sniffle
line or something
that [ __ ] sucks
yo um so before you went in
uh you were you obviously there's a very
public beef between you and rj
not anymore not no more i was going to
ask you man is a nice guy
yeah we're good now you guys you guys
got past that yeah i mean we got past it
before i went to jail i said i don't
know what
i don't know i guess that was the only
thing they could use in my case i don't
know
to make it look like something i guess
how dope was the uh
moment were you in jail when him and
greedo did their show
yeah did you hear about it when you were
in jail i'm the one told greed ought to
do it
i told him don't take it don't take it
forward it's not gonna go nowhere
right make some money off it if you're
gonna do it then they had the show
so yeah was that dope to see like
because that was a i think
that's gonna like in 10 years 20 years
from now that's going to be one of those
moments in l.a hip-hop history
yeah that we might not have known how
special it was
but the fact that those two crews were
on stage at the same time
i guess nothing happened it was peaceful
yeah that's like i guess that was like
the first verses then if you want it was
the first verses if you want to
be technical yeah a hundred percent yeah
that's real
what about what greedo uh do you keep in
contact with him right write him
yeah you're talking soon how's he doing
how's his spirits he's straight
i was talking to him in jail i stopped
talking because he said i was getting
him in trouble
so i stopped talking to you guys in the
same job i i in
texas but i don't know i guess he said
he got in trouble because they knew i
don't know they said they knew that he
was in another jail car or something i
don't know
oh [ __ ] do they still do the thing in
jail because
all my cousins are in prison and they
would to do three ways
they used to like yell on the phone like
for a while to like just like confuse
the phone lines
and then patch someone in on three-way
do they still do that no you don't got
to do that anymore you could just call
have somebody else
call them right through her nah and that
must have been a long
time ago
[Laughter]
you know what i'm talking about yeah
because they used to do that he knows
yeah if you try to dial another number
on
it's not gonna yeah they stopped doing
it you could just call it now
that was like six years or seven years
ago you know when i was like i remember
my cousin used to just hit my phone and
be like yo look
i got my celli he's gonna three-way his
baby mama she's gonna give you some
money
you're gonna send it to me but i'm i
gotta make this noise and
yeah sometimes they're blowing the phone
or something yeah it so you won't know
here the buttons that they died
so being locked up are you a celebrity
oh yeah for sure it's more than the
streets you run into all the people that
all the people that comment on your
pictures and stuff they'd be like i was
at this show i was doing this i counted
on your picture on this day but you
never know because it's jail so you
don't think like
groupies like that is that a um is it a
good thing to be in your position like
that
like it's good and bad because you might
have like
the people that don't like you it's easy
like if you're going to walk the main
line it's
easy for people to get you then you got
the people that like you
you got the police that like you but
then you got the police that don't like
you
so yeah it's kind of half was there
guards that would like look out for you
yes there's a bunch of them it was like
two or three that didn't like me i don't
know what it was but well most
because there's there's the cool guards
because it's not a bad career you just
make it a decent check
and then there's the ones who are like
they put out they take out all their
aggression other prisoners because
they're
either racist or they hate their life
yeah or you know they [ __ ] getting
[ __ ] by exactly why they working
whatever all these
shifts and over time and they take it
out on you yeah because they mad
you got the ones that that just here
just because it's a job they don't even
care about the job it's just a good
paying job so they like all right
whatever bro i listen to your music like
all right that's cool
sometimes you got the ones that act like
they let's do a musical they know who
you are but
they don't really [ __ ] with you right
that's a lot of those too
that's so funny yo the thing that you uh
you just mentioned in it
i think it was a no jumper but you
talked about how soldier boy was locked
up there
yeah he was in pc for people who don't
know that's protective custody
usually pc is child molesters
yep uh like sex offenders sex offenders
child molesters green lighters people
don't want it
right snitches yeah etc
who wants to be out with them right
that's what's confusing to me right
because
you if you're in that position you
almost have to ask for that or fight for
that
or do you think that the jail realized
no we got to put him over here because
he sold your boy i don't do that chris
brown wasn't in pc
so why was he in
the pc chris brown wasn't in peace no
hey chris brown's a real one little kid
yeah that's what i'm saying
like and he's like like a rnv pop dude
so how
if he didn't go to pc what is his excuse
if he's big draco
gangster rapper whatever then he's
supposed to be killing a [ __ ] before
like bro [ __ ] crazy it's funny because
you were in jail during his whole entire
like 60 day yeah i was there
his career got revamped for about two
months yeah and then like you said it
was just the meme thing yeah
it was really just a meme moment and
then the meme was over
and you know that's how it is man you
know i didn't realize it's like that
with this rap [ __ ] like
people do anything to get attention it's
like they just do like
i didn't think it really was like that
until i started seeing like
damn like people really just start beeps
because they like about to put out a mix
table or album or something like bruh
it's not that serious if you pop me you
pop in like
whatever take some time tyga came back
hey if tiger came back i tell this man
you're just one hit away
because people counted that man out
that's what i'm saying and i heard
six seven one radio when you went to
jail it was over for tiger
yeah i heard this [ __ ] on the radio
what was that that tastes like oh yeah
this is
okay i like this uh then i start hearing
back-to-back stuff like wow
that guy he's been having a run
yeah he's been having a run for sure
yeah uh shout out to tyga
uh let me ask you this i i saw that you
back in the day had you had a
relationship with mustard he tried to
sign you yeah
you would essentially kind of obviously
didn't go that way yeah
um what's your relationship with him now
i feel like musters evolved a lot yeah
as far as because i feel like you know
back in the day he had some issues with
some people in the city
and i feel like he's gotten past a lot
of those issues um
and any uh has he tapped in with you
since you've got
straight i talked to him i was like
ain't no hard feelings he's straight
and he's just telling everybody just
stay out the way [ __ ] like that all
right
i'm like yeah i know that other than
that we cool
i ain't got no problems with him i'm
cool with everybody man i don't be for
nobody
i'm straight hey that's good man yeah
that's how you stay out you know what
i'm saying yeah pretty much
because i figured it out like i was
talking to my brother and people they're
just like
we starting to think like people just
want to be with you on purpose so you
could go back to jail again and they can
get their little giant
then i started thinking about i'm like
yeah that might be that might be true
right because i wasn't getting out
talking [ __ ] to nobody i mean i talk
[ __ ] all the time but i wasn't just
getting out just talking i started
seeing people come for me i started
seeing people selling me i'm like damn
you would think people would be happy
like
i didn't tell nobody i beat the death
penalty
i put a lot of like i'm the reason a lot
of people feeding their kids
they got on when i was in jail off of my
[ __ ] bro like everyone knows this is not
a secret it's my [ __ ]
but you know i guess people are
unappreciative
and then it's almost like imagine if
like tupac came back in the year 2000
it would just be [ __ ] up for like ja
rule and like you know what i'm saying
yeah wait a minute the real one is here
oh yeah you know what i'm saying
nose ring
like imagine if like out of nowhere
tupac just dropped
dropped back to earth in the year 2000
it would have been
rough out here for a lot of people yeah
i don't know if you would have made it
in 2020 you know it's a whole different
world
you're right it's a different world they
put everything on the internet
everything is like i can't get on live
or none of that every time i get on live
it's on youtube they snatch everything i
do down
they probably had half the songs already
on youtube before they came out
like whatever oh we're uh breaking down
this video
we're not breaking it down we're taking
a break in the video to tell you all
about our sponsors odd socks all right
listen man uh oddssocksofficial.com
what the [ __ ] was that bro uh it was
like a [ __ ] pomeranian hair floating
in air
anyway odd socksofficial.com keyword
bootleg kev
go over there get you some socks and
you'll save 20 off if you use that
keyword they got south park
license they got some ghostbusters pimp
c
mike tyson really the one that i really
care about is they got that wwe license
you can get these awesome nwo socks
and then they got their odd socks basics
you know for all the basic [ __ ] get
you some basic socks
even though they are very comfortable uh
they're probably the most comfortable
socks
actually not probably definitively the
most comfortable socks i've ever put on
my feet
yes all right and that goes for all
types of socks
so go to oddssocksofficial.com get some
socks by the way
spongebob socks the kind of fly right
christmas time is on the way
use the keyword boulet kev 20 off
oddssoxoficial.com
support us by supporting odd socks let's
go i wanted to talk to you about your
delivery man
uh-huh your delivery is so unique
yeah it's one of a kind it is definitely
one of a kind
i want to like as a rapper where
did do you draw inspiration from as an
emcee
uh i'm not really inspired by nobody but
it was people i listen to like okay
is she cool like i like the rocco he
like yeah he was cool yeah
delivery atlanta shout out to rock a lot
of people don't know he signed future
exactly yeah but uh him i like the young
joe he yeah he was cold
young dro so slight how would he drop
that first album with uh
what grant hussell was so slept on i
like people
like robert yeah she was crazy and then
i was his battle rapper nobody really
know about him because
it was oh his name was like jungle cocky
or something he
he kind of made me start rapping i was
like oh you could say like
crazy stuff and still be calm with it
and don't be yelling
it he'd be saying something yeah cause
you have a very like
um your flow is very relaxing it's like
it's
it's like it's very easy to digest yeah
you know what i'm saying it's like so
many people be yelling in the studio and
all this and i'm like
i'm the type of person like even in real
life i'm not gonna be yelling going back
and forth with you to get my point
across
i'll just rap like that like and i want
people to be like dang how did you just
say something so crazy and just say it's
so kind
like you're like i don't know are you
were you born
like out were you originally born out
here yeah so you're born and raised here
my whole life
your whole life a lot of a lot of
atlanta influence though
yeah yeah i guess nah [ __ ] right
i mean rocco yeah yeah they're from
droves but
ain't really influenced me i just like
like okay cool
like yeah young joe needs his flowers
man
joe slept on bro yeah joe's a cold guy
dude for real for real
put a mic there oh just turn it yeah
it's all right
all right um yeah that's the one thing
like i think that you're
like like you said i think that there
has there have been some people that
have
tried to do what you do yeah they don't
they can't do it though
but you're very it's just like a one of
a kind
is this the way you do it it's like a
chrysler 300 and a bentley yeah pretty
much by the way i have a price with 300
it's paid off
no car payment it's like ford and
ferrari like
right right right right right that's
fair um
do you have like when you're when you're
locked up right you gotta help me
understand this because
what like how did you entertain yourself
throughout the day
as far as your free time was it
meditating was it reading
because you guys don't got the internet
and [ __ ] out over there nah reading
where i had people playing music on the
phone you guys like different
technically the phone's contraband right
yeah yeah but on a regular phone right
right right right oh so people will play
using [ __ ] over the phone
so that's all i know about a lot of
stuff yo what's the worst song you heard
over the
oh a song that i really just did
like you were like wait that's it
because there's been a lot of [ __ ] that
came out since you got locked up that
you're like hmm
that's interesting yeah i was just
it's from atlanta so it was almost
oh i have an idea who it is
i know the truth let me see i have an
idea who lives it's crazy
tall guy i don't know bro
he's a nice guy yeah i mean that's why i
don't do all that i didn't like it
though
don't know that's fair shout out to
whatever
anyway i don't care whatever um
i just grabbed that out of thin air
didn't they yeah i could get money
though so that's no no
um and now like you get out this kovach
is booming you can't do live shows
were you you've never really done the
big tour thing right no
i was supposed to i can't as yeah right
yeah it's crazy because now you gotta
like almost
figure out a new like are you gonna be
doing merch
because yeah you do that merch drop
you're gonna hit a lick that too
right now yeah where can they go to buy
the merch
uh what is it home bro it's the hives
this is the hives backslash draco
there we go yeah the high backslash
draco the hives yeah
is there um you know what's dope about
being independent like i know you're
indie right now oh you get all the money
you get all the money um but i also it's
i mean everyone's got to be knocking on
your door trying to sign you oh yeah for
sure is
a lot of people i mean they've been
doing that when i was in jail that was
like
right so what will it take what's
important to you
to even think about that because i don't
think you need to sign with anybody
i don't i mean i'm the most influential
person to come out of here like
everybody wants to be me i always said
that it'd be rappers that'd be like
i want to sign him i'm too big of a
rapper to be signed to another rapper
like i don't know i get enough money
like
to be like for them to be trimming my
money or giving me front of me some
money and then i gotta pay it back
like how am i gonna pay it back right
now anyway if i sign the deal
how am i going to pay that money back
hey you got the right i can't do no
shows
you got the right thought process hey
come on bro i'm not i'm not [ __ ]
cause you know everything right
hey i'm gonna pay back 99 out of 100
people would go to that
upfront bag and worry about the
wrestling it's like all the people that
signed autumn deals not even dead now
yeah can't do no shows they didn't
french furniture all this money and then
and then you ain't making money off your
music because you're
cooped come on so i hope you held on to
that event yeah and know that they did
it and they did
for sure they did not that's crazy
that [ __ ] is crazy uh i saw your auntie
was in here
she's an integral part of your career
yeah how important is it to keep
everything close and in the family man i
mean it's
i don't know you gotta keep them close
because it's a lot of people like i just
she was there the whole time i was in
jail so that's why i always got her
around
but i don't know it's a lot yeah
it's a lot of stuff you going on you got
to keep people you trust around because
i didn't have people steal money from me
all type of [ __ ] when i was in jail so
people were stealing from you while you
were in jail what
sure and what like in what capacity
because like
like like you know you're locked up you
have you got i'm assuming there's some
liquidity somewhere yeah people i'm
letting people you know
people who you trusted people i'm
trusted use my car
pull out money handle things for me oh
they was pulling out money out of your
cards
yeah pulling out [ __ ] so you get out of
jail
you then you you're like expecting you
got a certain amount of money in the
bank
yeah yeah but i had two i had like a
business account or other one so i was
expecting to
get some money from the homie and oh
yeah go put this out for me hey
damn bro for real twenty thousand
dollars huh
so 20 badges is missing yeah luckily i'm
a different person now
yeah that's a lot of money that's a lot
of money but the eyes are on you right
now
you know it might be
safe to say those people aren't around
anymore no they're not damn
i can only imagine bro hey exactly right
hey you know what let me ask you this
man it was looking kind of grim for you
for a minute
were did you ever go through any sort of
phase of being depressed while you were
locked up oh yeah for sure i mean i was
fighting the death penalty like you
don't know like
it's always like you hear people fight
stuff like that so you'll never be like
you never think you're going to be that
person you sitting there and somebody
said that you're like
that's not me then when you that person
you don't know when you just going to
court just to go to court
you don't know what's going on and not
offering you no deal
like you get crazy sometimes you get the
weather in like damn
am i ever going to get out right or even
if i do get out am i still going to be
relevant when i get out is it even going
to matter
who wants to get out of jail when they
40 something
how to be a rapper at 40 something right
come on bro
luckily like i'm probably i'm going to
be the biggest rapper ever to come out
because i'm the youngest like everybody
that went through like i'm 27 i just
turned 27
so like everybody gucci man all them
people when they was going through their
stuff they was all ordered to me when
they got out and started blooming right
right
i'm still in my 20s so i give it like
five more years and i'm just
trying to do something else maybe since
you've been out uh i even got some dope
features on the project obviously oh
yeah for sure
i think it's dope you you and stupid
young linked up oh yeah is he somebody
that's my boy i know i've been
he's great yeah i've been i know him
from jail though yeah he's a good dude
man
um alex who has who has tapped in with
you
uh since you've been out that that
you know there's like your story was
very high profile
yeah so a lot of people knew what was
going on so has there been any
artists that have tapped out since you
got out to try to work oh yeah uh rowdy
hit me
uh like a lot of people that been
hitting me though like
uh jay chris uh
it's so many people um the what's
made in tokyo oh yeah he's a homie uh
um a lot of people like reaching them
but i already had songs
how crazy was it to what witness roddy's
uh
ascension to stardom while you were
locked yeah that's just crazy because i
was like
because when you when you i think when
you got when you got like he was making
some noise yeah he was yeah but yeah
yeah but he wasn't like i mean last
night around that time
he's one of the biggest artists on the
planet yeah i've seen it yeah i heard
the box but
i knew that song was going to blow up
when i heard it i was like
that's your heart so is there going to
be a rottie record coming i don't know
man you got a example
that'd be big for the city man yeah
that'd be big bro
i'll just be focusing on what i got
going on because worried about what
other people got going actually gonna
stress you out and throw you off your
game you gotta worry about yourself
that's why i am the t grizzly feature
was dope too i think yeah
isn't that one of those guys who talks
that talk yeah
did you ever work with mozzie before you
got locked up yeah no he was on my
second
second mixtape he was on there a lot of
people don't know that but he was on
there
it's crazy because i feel like now like
with you being independent like
there's been this trend your indy link
up with another independent artist drop
a whole project
yeah pretty much i'm trying to do
something real you got to drop a tape
fire yeah he's funny he's not about the
only person that i think could [ __ ] with
me
or just on on a whole oh no just let's
talk [ __ ] this is what i do bro i
i do this all day so did you have it
were you like
you know what's crazy because when i
hear you i i guess i'm like
i feel like you like did you ever listen
to sugar free when you was growing up
not like that but he is funny as hell i
started listening to
in prison i was like wow he was saying
yo it's so crazy to think
that sugar-free couldn't exist in 2020
they'd have cancelled them
yeah they'd have cancelled his ass oh
what happened i didn't know that
no i just mean just because he was
talking about all kind of what you can't
say the [ __ ] he was saying
in 2020 yeah yeah these [ __ ] yo
you know what's crazy is since you've
been out there's this new [ __ ] it was
always around but bigger than ever this
is cancel culture [ __ ] yeah that's weird
so no matter what you do you could
they'll dig up an old tweet
yeah i heard about it i i was seeing
that [ __ ] on tv i didn't think it was
real though oh it's real
yeah i seen they was doing it to a lot
of people bro they just tried to cancel
sata baby for like five-year-old tweets
like
[ __ ] it's like like i gotta delete some
[ __ ] you might wanna dig in
wipe that [ __ ] clean oh man cause damn
man
there's people out here whose whole life
they're just waiting to be offended on
the internet
yeah i know i know i had to yeah i know
it's crazy so your situation are you on
probation are you totally
yeah i'm on probation but i'm not i
don't got to check in or nothing
so it's not it's unsupervised yeah
pretty much how long
how long five years five that's a long
time in it fire
that [ __ ] is damn long time
but at least it's unsupervised yeah when
everything opens back up
hopefully that you know that i don't
know is it gonna be the type of
probation where you gotta get permission
to leave the state type [ __ ]
i mean yeah but i don't i don't think
they tripping like that
because they weren't even tripping
before they just want me to get
catch a charge that's what they want i
don't think they tripping on nothing
like that
yeah hopefully they just kind of moved
on like all right you know what we tried
yeah
pretty much i would hope we got to let
them out now yeah but
i know they're watching me though for
sure you're watching me yeah just be
smart man you know casanova just got
those rico chargers man i've seen that
i've seen she herbal too herbal had to
turn herself in on some fraud [ __ ]
but that rico nothing for that though
yeah but the rico [ __ ] is yeah that's
that's like the six nine [ __ ] i don't
oh that's life that carry life yo i
gotta get your perspective you know it's
funny because you mentioned six nine i
gotta just get your perspective
as because you were in jail throughout
his whole his whole entire [ __ ]
yeah like the highs he's getting locked
up and then he'll get out and snitching
crazy like that [ __ ] is
it's crazy to even fathom that that
even happened i mean but what do you
expect from a [ __ ] with rainbow hair
bro
funny though you know i give it to he
was funny i liked it though he mastered
that it was funny
no one has mastered the internet and the
trolling better now mind you he was
doing some dangerous [ __ ]
he was but you can't you can't do that
you can only do that
to a certain extent you could do all
that if you really from the streets and
you really like a street [ __ ]
but if you're not like that it's gonna
always come back to bite you
like me i'm from the streets i talk [ __ ]
that's cool
but whatever i'm not in the same
position as him
he had to pay people you know a type of
[ __ ] to hang around him i don't pay
people to hang around me
i grew up with all these people very
very very um so it's different
i'm these people's ticket out the game
so i don't think people want to play
with me like that but i'm not
nobody like when you say that there's a
lot of people
who who unfortunately they do have to
come to l.a yeah and they have to pay
attention
yeah for sure right i'm not one of those
people but that's only like out of town
or people
no i'm saying they got to check in i
mean that's anywhere though but we
i guess i'll hear it just stricter like
i want to ask you this right because
does everyone need to check in or only
people who have that street persona when
they come to l.a
if you're like a gangster rapper and you
come to l.a or detroit you got to check
in with certain people yeah pretty much
but if it's like
logic like there's a lot like logic does
probably doesn't like your puzzles i'm
pretty sure they're going to get up on
them too
like uh now if you're somebody like dirk
or thug or somebody on
they're not going for that right right
right right but
other people oh yeah they got to play i
think
i think too like a lot of people don't
realize like yo man like
you can't just let your guard down out
here you can't no matter
you know rest in peace to pop smoke yeah
like he was in the hills bro yeah
exactly
good kid can't trust nobody can't trust
nobody bro
and and a lot of people we've lost since
you've been locked up
yeah ex like lots of people i like that
[ __ ]
and uh i think you know
for for you you know being on probation
and
and and i think it's dope that you got a
second chance man pretty much
it seems like you got your your you know
you got your head in the right place
to go on a big run pretty much yeah i
mean i don't got nothing to do anybody
but to record it's nothing nowhere to go
so all i can do is make music and since
i'm independent i'm going to get all
that money so
yeah there it is man hey
how many unreleased tk how many
unreleased greeto songs are there still
in the cut
how many i knew i knew it because he
dude
1400 songs today so cool
yo i feel like you got to grab like 10
of them and do the the the greato draco
project
yeah that'll be big bro
is that something that you guys have
have brainstormed about doing like a
project where you
don't do that before i can in jail yeah
so that's something that's already in
in the air pretty much and you got 1400
songs to choose from
so if he's got 1400 and you just crank
the album out in five days
yeah how many how many songs do you got
we haven't heard
well a lot i mean i wrote 209 songs in
jail
so like i got a lot of yeah i got a lot
every single song that was on my mixtape
i wrote in jail
every single one so you know most people
can't write
all you had to do was come out and get
the beats and just go straight in and
lay them down
i just that's why i tested it out with
this mixtape and apparently people like
everything that i wrote in jail
because when i wrote in jail i
visualized it as if i was on the streets
so you can't write if you in jail nobody
want to hear that all day people talking
about jail
i don't want to hear and i was in jail
so right right right well listen man um
your project is out yeah you know the
truth there's gonna be a whole lot more
coming
a lot more coming hopefully a greedo
project yeah
i feel like that's only right pretty
much that's the homie
yeah yeah shout out to him man he's in
good spirits and free grater free
free greedo uh and uh thank you for
coming through man
you're the latest rapper we've ever had
for the record oh yeah what
what's up tj yes there we go afraid of
stick team free kills free rozzy
free everybody boom you know the truth